e da quant'è che non usciva un horror ma
sarà da quando ho fatto slann derm e nel
2012 dell tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono poi j proprio lui solo
su we went black cose viventi beck non
ne ho la più pallida idea però so che è
stato portato benissimo chi se ne frega
andiamo a voglio giocare spaventarmi
come faccio da sei anni bailey scoppiata
sono sette prove
anzi 8 perché si sente averlo fatto nel
2012 quindi 8 partenza un in fallout
buongiorno che bello mi piace svegliarmi
da da queste la partenza di de che il
costo è la madonna cosa diavolo esista
nuova ragazza è bellissimo è fatto
strabene il suo gioco ma se viene una
navicella e ho capito ma mi spiego
meglio
siamo in una vicenda atterrata quello
stavo dicendo interact proteico back
cover up e prendi la hadopi cast del
brand l'ho presa al ve se qualcuno di
voi per caso si stacca e un problema
questa è una sorta di mix tra alle isole
shawn e slider mens vogliamo perché
siamo partiti
puoi zoomare con gli occhi quindi has
lander man's law che le serve nello
spazio lander space luce un topo sto
girando in tondo basta come si ma no
tanto non c'era neanche l'effetto sonoro
di farla con l'effetto sonoro gianpi
vedi come mi spaventa come si ma no
devono insegnare io che dovete vedere
gli effetti sonori e gli horror porco
demonio è un gioco ai tv pt è un gioco
dove ribelli sempre la stessa zona per
ogni volta cambia e quindi è un pt
insomma ho capito scavalca lo no allora
mi fino qua l'inter accusa some say to
vabbè mar no no no ma no ma no ma no ma
no ma no ma allora sei stupido cedillo e
dirlo che non l'hai fatto l'asilo billo
dillo che ti picchiavano da piccolo
nonna dare bruno bruno rosa era
chiaramente venuto di qua però non se
non si è capito l'olanda dove io torno
indietro
me ne vado trattato il tifo è sparito
era qua devo fare le foto da qualche
parte di qualsiasi tipo
le piantine c'è il topo dopo i ragazzi
sotto pon ora io ve lo dico no no no no
no no non corri corri corri corri corri
minchia ho sentito il tizio che sta
arrivando fortissimo non so da dove meno
cioè vendere che non si vede dietro
niente si chiude ripartiamo ogni volta
l'acqua non stavolta non sono partito la
loro prima
stavolta la stanza quella appena prima
quella del biliardo è pieno di miliardi
va bene cosa devo fare qua le foto dei
foto
prendi la bella cosa
ho fatto una foto a una cosa che non ho
capito va bene continuiamo così qualcosa
su 100 stamane messo qua è utilissimo
fase 8 time space che ciò che veramente
marca però averi che c'è una porta non
continuare a girare
apri glie l'ho fatta la foto è ma non mi
piace per il buongiorno
sono un po pagato da solo mare qua
serve ma lei è veramente brutto non ti
aprire non ti aprire non ti apri 20
aprile va bene c'è uno veramente meno
male che io sono uscito bello potevano
essere frutto anch'io parte che non c'è
uno specchio vi non lo possiamo appurare
però qualcuno ha tirato una testata al
vetro dalla tua madre che palle ogni
volta deve succede nella roma le ogni
volta video piani infarto che non ha un
senso che guarda che cosa è rotto ma
pure pure si è rotto il soffitto ci
mancava quello e il dopo
dove sta il tuo papà ho trovato una mano
va bene va bene va bene facciamo l'ha
fatto anche al topo il topo è morto non
c'è il topo ok sta cambiando un po la
faccenda voi ragazzi va bene perché
sentito rumori non vi muovete di figlio
a schiaffi vincano desiderare casco no
no posso tornare qua sotto torno qua
sotto
che la donna vita non ci tornavo
permesso bruno metto levi polaroid si
può mettere a vedi sì a quelle che ho
fotografato prima ho capito non ci sono
le lettere io che cacchio ne so chi sono
sti rumori orribili che è porca vacca me
mancando polaroid dove era tanto quello
di prima
sparito lato
la foto uno di quei non averla faccio la
porta a voi non volete foto profilo foto
profilo di facebook
buongiorno lei un po magro sa guardi che
qua c'è una bellissima palestra possiamo
fare i paesi insieme mi dice la sua
dieta ci ha voglia
lei è il gigante magro mi scusi si può
effettivamente stare se visto che sei
brutto che tu mi all'iti in faccia ha
senso la huayra foto profilo no vabbè no
dai
e chi pulisce adesso pezzente schifoso
dai veramente spaccato tutto no il mio
topo è ancora vivo si muove guarda
carino che devo fà o ecco fotografo che
non ho capito sono tutti sti simboli che
devo trovare in giro per poi immetterli
sono questa specie di luna che devo
trovare per poi metterle tutte di fila
vicino a bruno però non ho capito il
senso e tutto ciò dai l'ha fotografata
basta adesso ne fa l'ultima due ore puoi
farmi prendere l'ultima foto prima di
portare perché sono dover strisciare
ogni volta nel condotto come sai ma lui
non sta nel come non li vedo più i siti
che era lui stava là dentro
ok a il vetro si è riparato perfetto
detto se li parato tutto a posto voi
fermi fermi perfetto lo tornare mettere
vabbè dai mettiamola avrei voluto
mettere tutti insieme a quel punto però
fa niente ne manca una che sta a bordo
non mi spuntare adesso per favore mi
manca una sola
allora per me o abiti per allora miei
figli per il culo di luca di t figlio
per il culo libero io una pre di cure
nel tempo liberava farei è però se ce
l'ha il tempo libero magari non ce l'hai
sono 8 ma non doveva andare così ha
quindi non devo toccarlo che ne so io
allora prendiamo st fare devo prendere
questo che un disco pick up avevamo
preso su bruno bruno vespa tutte le foto
allora e che famo vedevo in fila giuste
a questo mi dice le scritte ok
manutenzione guarda futile porco il
demonio si è andata è andato a fuoco
libreria bruno non sei futile stavo
scherzando semplicemente stanno andar
fuori tutti i ct gigi d'alessio
vabbè ma manos è stato bello no aprite
che vado che muoio soffocato giovanni la
porta
grazie no perchè questo va bene dove
sono i piedi del mio amato giovanni
ava tuttofuoco porco demonio io devo
uscire di qua teoricamente non si
condanni la io adesso credo che al
footing e si ha la password o sbaglio e
la password a fuoco anche di pil disegno
nella foto porco demi volée usa posso
usare la password per uscire e futile
che è che non sto morendo porca put sono
morto a vangol
dai che se la porta striscia dai
trattori respiro piuttosto figlio di
perché ci stanno tutti i gas in giro
storto quindi finito così non dovrà
esporre no
e iniziato ma che i bordi o io la sua
passione se futile la metto futile può
essere speriamo proprio lui
l'omessa promessa funzione attenzione
attenzione
ma io non ho capito un cazzo
[Musica]